so Joe Biden mocked Republicans who  pretend to care about the deficit or  whatever and I have to tell you this is  a great new Joe Biden or a lot more  Republicans taking credit for that bill  than we actually voted for it  I see them out there and now we're going  to build this new bridge here we're all  for it and by the way there's new road  and we're going to have an internet  that's going to be all the way I love  them man  they ain't got no shame I don't know  what's gotten into Joe Biden over the  last three months but on the one hand  you've got all the legislative  accomplishments and on the other hand  you have this sort of take no prisoner's  attitude from Joe Biden and whatever the  explanation is I love it and this is  exactly who I was hoping would be the  president when Joe Biden won quite  frankly it's not like my expectations  were absurdly high but I did hope for  this element of Joe Biden and we're  finally getting it